the latest images released by north
korea are striking on sunday it
test-fired an intermediate-range
ballistic missile the hwasong-12 that is
nuclear-capable it reached a height of
2000 kilometers taking pictures of the
korean peninsula along the way but it
has a range of 4500 kilometers far
enough to reach the u.s territory of
guam
but it's not the most powerful ballistic
missile in kim jong-un's arsenal in 2017
north korea tested the hwasong-14 and
15. the latter of which could in theory
reach the continental united states
and in 2020 it showed off an even larger
icbm which hasn't been tested yet north
korea has spent a lot of time uh an
investment in the past two or three
years certainly during covid in
developing some of its missile
capabilities and that that is aligned
very closely with the five-year weapons
plan that that north korea announced at
the beginning of 2021
with the aim to develop capabilities
that will enable the north korea to
fight a modern a modern conflict
the u.s wants direct talks with north
korea we've offered this over and over
to
to the prk and they've not accepted it
[Music]
so the question is what's kim jong-un's
game plan the north koreans aren't
actually really putting forward much
right now right i mean they have to
actually show up in order to strike a
deal with the biden people and so i'm
actually again i'm kind of surprised
with the pace of the test because my
sense is the dividing people are willing
to talk if the north koreans will show
up
it was north korea's seventh missile
test in january a new record its
self-imposed moratorium on missile tests
appears well and truly at an end andrew
chappelle al jazeera